let's shift over to the arizona
cardinals we still don't know what that
offense is going to look like although
if you pay attention to college football
and texas tech the air raid offense the
the ultimate version of that loose
college drawed up in the dirt will it
work at the nfl level and lamarcus
joyner the raiders safety said after the
game when the raiders played the
cardinals week two of the preseason he
described the offense as a pretty boy
offense and uh or pretty boy football
and some cardinals players took
exception to it justin pugh joked about
it he said yeah we got some good looking
guys what do you want from us but uh
is the is it like a lesser brand of
offense should should
old school hardcore football people look
down their nose at this kind of an
offense that the cardinals plan to run
chris i think it's fair to question it
and whether it can be successful i mean
we haven't really seen that many college
teams really win and go to national
championships winning that way right i
mean we really haven't when you talk
about alabama okay clemson might be
about as close as we've seen to that but
clemson doesn't like abandon the run
game i think there's a lot of questions
about how this offense will translate to
the nfl certainly for me you know i know
they're going to be able to get you know
some cheap yards in the past game and do
all those things but is there enough
inventory in that offense when it
becomes week three and week four and so
on where teams are starting to go ooh
there's tendencies here and when they
get in this formation they like to do
this and when they're in that formation
they do that
that's where i really worry about it
added to the fact of
i still think you got to get underneath
the center a little bit mike in the nfl
and come downhill and run the football
that way and i think that's what
lamarcus joyner joyner's looking at he's
going this is big 12 football this is
seven on seven that's why we talk about
big 12 being crappy at defense and
everything else and there's no physical
nature about the offense and i hope that
cliff kingsbury can unleash some of that
and get some downhill run game with
david johnson because i think he thrives
in that environment i also think it'll
help kyler murray mike if you can run
downhill the boo legs the play actions
getting him separated from the line of
scrimmage to where he can see the field
better a lot like we've seen from
russell wilson i think that will be a
very good tool for that offense to have
it's a very subtle point because you
can't have a running game out of the
shotgun but the difference is if you've
got an eye formation and you get the
snap instantaneously and you turn the
the running back has a head of steam
when he gets the ball and hits the hole
and that can develop more quickly the
play develops so much more slowly when
you run out of shotgun because first you
got to get the snap and then you got to
turn and your back is standing still
when he gets the ball
already running and going horizontal to
a degree
yeah and and you know again if you've
got a great offensive line it won't
matter but there's something to be said
for hitting the hole quickly and busting
through it to the second level it's
harder to do when you're running the
ball out of shotgun and also it's just
the variety chris the thing that that
that i always say the more you can make
the defense guess that's right a run is
it a pass and the longer you can delay
that process so why that's why the rpo
works so well yeah you you force the
defense to continue guessing after the
snap and then you wait for them to
commit and you burn them the other way
and and that's that offense lacks it and
and uh you're right after four or five
weeks and they see what they do and they
break down the film and they come up
with ways to confuse kyler murray and
and the and look
i i people people say oh kyle murray was
joking when he said to antonio brown why
they got to bring the house on me bro i
don't i think he was a little irritated
i think he's a little frustrated and
this is a guy who has not encountered
much adversity while playing football
it's always come easy to him i want to
see
how does kyler murray deal with a
three-game losing streak how does he
deal with a final stat line of five for
23 with two interceptions and 87 yards
if that happens how does how does he
react to that it's not going to be like
it was in college in high school and and
you know maybe that gives him the
determination to play even better to to
fit the ball through tighter windows to
to be a better quarterback to be more
dialed in he needs to be he needs to do
what deshaun watson did right sean
watson you know hey in college the
window's that big and sometimes he was
outside of it in the nfl the window's
this big and he threads the needle
that's right as needed and and will
caller murray step up to that he's got
the arm yeah ball's got the pop but it's
so much more than that yes it is and you
made all the right points about the i
formation and and again i i you know
i challenge people to listen to this
aspect too a lot of these defensive
players coming to the nfl are more
comfortable seeing this type of
arizona offense because that's what
they're seeing in college rather than
seeing
oh sean mcvay
sean payton josh mcdaniels kyle shanahan
whoa i formation guards are pulling holy
cow what do i do think about if you're a
linebacker playing that type of offense
oh there's todd gurley i gotta get to
him oh there's todd gurley i gotta get
to him oh there's todd gurley i gotta i
gotta get to him oh wait jared goff has
the ball oh man robert woods is behind
me now and it's a 20 yard completion
it's the best way to create explosive
plays and i think that's why you've seen
teams like the patriots the rams the
saints go that route here as of late
because one they've recognized college
football players are not used to seeing
the style of football right now this is
actually different even though it's old
school that you got guys like you and me
this is actually different for the new
school guys and a lot of young defensive
coaches don't even know how to defend it
defensive players don't know how to
defend it and it's a great way to get
explosive pass plays in the passing game
that's really the best part about it
one last point before we move on a wise
man once told me that any time a player
says something that is controversial
about an opponent or has some nickname
like pretty boy football chances are
they didn't come up with it chances are
they heard it in a meeting room
from either their head coach or their
coordinator right or that that this is
something that the raiders were saying
about the cardinals just because
lamarcus joyner is the one who said it
yeah there's a disdain among the raiders
coaching staff chris and it possibly
goes
all the way up to chucky himself calling
it pretty boy football but uh you know
that may have been something that ended
up on the cutting room floor for hard
knocks right but there's a chance that
that's where it came from i think you're
i would i would bet if you made me bet
if it came from that or lamarcus joyner
made it up himself i would imagine that
either in the secondary room or the
defensive full meeting room that that
came up during the week you're right
about that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports